hello freak [ __ ] have you like
completely moved past all the Cosby [ __ ]
or do you tilt still take grief for that
that grief no I've uh
well now you're vindicated I was never
grief is just where I would be for us to
talk about it in situations I didn't
want to and also it came out the the
joke and that video came out right
before we were starting the rollout from
my Comedy Central TV show and we
actually people that we push back my
announcement because they're looking
opportunist that news was that crazy
that we pushed it back by maybe he
pushed it back the premier announced by
a month or two Wow because it was that
and so so even though I had my Comedy
Central deal in place this insists 2012
I had all around Comedy Central deals so
then when that came out and then I got
my show with it well then my show was
scheduled to go on the air it looked
like oh you did a Cosby joke and then
you got the TV show no man this is like
my fourth development deal and this is
finally the show that I got a ha ha
isn't that funny how things that work
yeah but so that was that was the thing
where instead of instead of just having
this show that I was able to it was his
energy around you know in 2005 July like
yet all early 2005 it was just energy
around it where if I was gonna do press
around that time they were definitely
gonna what year was it this was 2015 two
years ago to tell you sorry yeah 2015
and that show in Philly was October 2014
so yeah it just kind of really affected
the the energy around it as far and and
my want and an eagerness to do
a lot of press just because I knew it's
gonna come up yeah and I was just like I
was so that was that how I'm not saying
it that's the reason my shells not on
anymore you know just before people like
your show sucked
that's why is it
you